i buy into the birth order uh  personality traits that if you're  surrounded by many siblings and you're  kind of stuck in the middle  you uh probably need to find ways to get  attention or to separate yourself from  the pack and i think that definitely  applies to some elements my personality  and one thing i learned about middle  children which you guys might find  interesting is i recently took a ghost  tour in savannah  and during the yellow fever epidemic  people did it was kind of like early  covert they didn't know how it spread  but people were dying left and right and  so if you had an uncle  who died you had to get the body to the  graveyard and you would like knock on  this crypt and like put it in this crypt  or whatever but they would always send  the middle child to go do that because  they were expendable